[музыка]
Да, сейчас будет очень интересно.
Пейзажи космические. Идём перевалами.
[музыка]
Казахский. Мы сейчас с вами вот здесь
Казахстан, Монголия, Китай и Россия. Вы
будете здесь. В принципе, и на западе у
нас там наши берецские курганы или сам
лозунг
выские государственности по
притокамшающихся
в Россию, в Монголию. Вот да идеально.
В этом туре мы поедем. У нас есть два
маршрута. Первый маршрут, э, длинный,
1.200 км, но, скорее всего, мы не будем
по нему идти, потому что он
подразумевает похоту. Ну, реально очень
много времени тратить на езду. И мы,
наверное, поедем по маршруту 900 км, где
езды тоже будет вот так в районе 6 часов
езды. И у нас ещё будет куча времени для
разборов, разговоров и так далее.
Поэтому моя цель такая, чтобы в этом
багитуре вы все кайфанули от природы, от
экстрима, от вождения магии и чтобы
каждый из вас уехал с загруженной
головой в плане того, чёткое понимание,
где у него проблема, в чём заключается
лечение и план на следующий год, как он
будет дальше развиваться.
Меня зовут Алмаз с города Алмааты, 32
года, жена двоих детей. Занимаюсь
логистикой более 10 лет. Я занимаюсь
организацией концертов. У меня оркестр,
я сам дирижёр.
Меня зовут КЗТ с Солнечного Ташкента.
Занимаюсь кондитерским делом. Мы
являемся сетью номер один общественного
питания в Узбекистане. Компания
занимается поставкой материалов для
отопления, для вентиляции IT. Э, работаю
в крупной американской корпорации HIT
Packer Enterprise. С недавнего момента
мы возглавляем весь офис по СНГ
поставкой.
Я родом из Минска, сейчас живу.
История такая же, как у Гарими его
зовут. Он изчитаться.
Круто. Что вы хотели бы это услышать?
Вабсолютно национальной канины.
Сейчас, собственно говоря, я считаю,
самое крутое - это не делать стейки из
американского мяса, да? Делать на идти
на собственный рынок, смотреть, что
делают ваули, наши сельхозники,
аграрники, и вот из этих продуктов
делать крутую, интересную еду. Это
гораздо круче для меня, чем просто там
пиццерию открыть, ну,
пасту делать и так далее.
красиво
[музыка]
Вообще настроение отличное, когда
выезжаешь сюда, аж после выезда жить
хочется, а туда приезжаешь, постоянно
проблем. Ещё что-то здесь обо всём
забываешь.
Я думаю, будет очень интересно. В этот
раз больше народу. А теперь, э, что вы
делаете? Сейчас разбираем каски. Каска
на всю на всю неделю. Вот взяли и всё.
Только с ней разбираем, э, баф. Его
обязательно чтоб шея не сгорела. Можно
как пыльник использовать, можно как.
Рекомендую ещё использовать как
посленник.
Смотрите, баги быстрые. Я понимаю, здесь
кто-то ралли ещё где-то участвовал.
Здесь чуть другой формат. Попробуйте
его. Здесь строгая дисциплина, никто
никого не обгоняет. Строго идём в
колонии по нумерации. Ваши нумерации на
тот день по рации. Если вам кричат
третий, третий, значит это вам кричат.
По именам нам долго вспоминать. Если, не
дай бог, какая-то ситуация, не пытайтесь
руки и ноги вытащить из баги. Если вот
вы переворачиваетесь, ваше движение вот
руки здесь уже. Ну за рулём ты не за
рулём, отпустился, держишься вот здесь.
Руки не вытаскивай. Ещё раз повторюсь,
имён ни у кого нету. Когда вам кричат в
рацию, третьей баги. Сегодня вы третий,
завтра восьмой, завтра шестой. С утра
сели в третьй баге. Всё, это ваш номер.
Так, ну вот сейчас готовимся к выезду,
настраиваем связь. Вот. Разбираемся с
баги. В общем, готовность номер один,
как говорится.
немного есть страх, чтобы перевернуть
пару раз,
но пока первое время буду пассажиром.
เฮ
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
Мы сейчас выезжаем. У нас впереди 132 км
горной и лесной дороги. А сейчас вначале
сначала короткий маршрутик до обеда, а
потом после обеда будем месить грязь.
[музыка]
Впечатления классные, на самом деле.
Здесь очень красиво. Это только начало,
а мы уже видели, смотрите, очень
красивые виды. Это первый опыт у меня
езды на баге. Я пока ехал, думал, нужно
мне купить, наверное, тоже баги.
Оторвали здесь мы сейчас прямо хорошо.
Это только вот только начало. Блин,
первый час огонь.
Природа, ребята, бомба.
Да, отличная вода.
Да
идуля тебе здоровья, брат.
Вода хорошая.
Да, чтобы ты всегда вот так людей
встречал, провожал. Вода магическая.
Заходишь, холодно, потом купаешься,
становится жарко. В баге я спал, бля.
Проснулся уже речки.
Серьёзно?
Да. А так вода бодрящая, хорошая,
хорошее настроение.
Водичка отличная, бодрящая,
супер.
Когда он видит в таком коллекти? 21
[музыка]
Дороги плохие, техническое сопровождение
не прошло. Остаются одни баги. Мы
надеемся только на себя.
Поехали спасать вторую команду.
Как всегда, техника
канаp
помогает выйти нашей технической службе
и операторам
Багитуре, экспедиции Маргувана
Колиевича.
Ну и мы, инструктора сопровождения
Кайра и Олега, вытаскиваем эту тяжёлую
технику, которая не может порой пройти.
[музыка]
О.
Так, мы девятый идём. А поступил сигнал
от десятого, что у него перегрев э
мотора. Остановилась колонна. И вот
вместе с инструктором решаем текущий
вопрос. Почистили.
Смотрите,
видите? Че?
Почистили девятый. Теперь помогаем
десятому. Взаимовыручка. เฮ
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
เฮ
[музыка]
немного чувствуется небольшая усталость.
А так вообще потрясающе, на мой взгляд.
Природа вообще удивительная.
Вот эти горы, переходящие в равнины.
Первый день прошёл нормально. Вот
приехали уставшие, весёлые. Сейчас
покушаем, пообщаемся, ляжем спать,
зарядимся. Так что всё впереди.
Давай. Ну что, прошло всё вообще
мегакруто. Очень, очень жёсткая дорога
была. Прям преодолевали, да. У нас там
дерево такое прямо бомбическое было, а
нам пришлось его объезжать. Было
немножко страшновато, но прикольно.
Первая часть была очень лёгкая, вторая
часть была жесть. В лесу пару раз
застряли, еле вытащили машину. Ну вот
добрались.
[музыка]
Я э много передач смотрел Маргула
Николеевича. Я почему сюда приехал?
Собственно говоря, это то же самое, что,
как меня отец воспитывал.
Примерно такой же путь жизненный прошёл,
плюс-минус относительно.
И у него есть там одно выступление.
Я не родился для того, чтобы охранять
свой свою еду
пасти свою еду.
Да, этот чабан и я чабан. Поэтому эта
школа примерно у нас одинаковая.
Да. Да.
Я вот хочу вам подарить вот эту бурку
шабанскую.
О, конкретная.
А это не лишнего будет.
О, вот это вот это да. Госпо
[музыка]
ничего. Как я?
А где музыка теперь?
Гурка без папаха это никуда.
Вот. Вот это да.
Сейчас я буду блондином.
Ди когда-то сам щел шапки.
Да я се почк. Вот такие шапки я здесь.
О, как я кур
курка и папаха. Без кинжал этого горе.
А как ты провёл? Как ты кинжал провёл?
[__]
Мой номер с моим номером 0,20 как раз
с его номером.
Фотори
у нас пару должников придёт. Я вам
подарю.
Вообще технология
моего разбора, она строится навсегда на
поиске нахождения узкого горлышка. Что
такое узкое горлышко? В любой системе, в
любой системе в единицу времени в данный
момент существует только одно и только
одно узкое горлышко. Не бывает два узких
горлышка, не бывает тричетыре пять,
бывает только одно узкое горлышко. Но
свойство узкого горлышка в том, что вот
здесь ты его
разошьёшь, оно в другом месте
переместится. Узкое горошко всегда
меняется. Потяните бумагу, попробуйте
порвать её. Не там, где я надрезал,
невозможно. Вы всегда будете рвать в
узком месте. Хоть дёргайте, хоть
медленно рвите, хоть любое
вознаграждение, если вы будете тянуть
вот листочек, полоску бумаги, я
чуть-чуть здесь надрежу, всегда будет
рваться там, где надрезано. Согласны?
Да.
Это экспериментально доказано много раз.
То же самое цепь. Цепь. Цепь рвётся.
Сила цепи определяется самым слабым
звеном.
И заметьте, когда цепь рвётся, она
никогда не рвётся в двух местах, трёх
местах и так далее. Она рвётся только в
одном месте.
Только или в народе ещё говорят, рвётся
там, где тонко. Поэтому, если брать цепь
как систему, как бы вы не рвали, она
будет рваться только в одном месте.
[музыка]
Первая ночь за 3 дня, которую удалось
выспаться. Впечатления отличные.
Вот погода хорошая. Первый денься.
А сегодня маршрут будет отличаться.
Будут больше степных дорог, горы будут,
речки будут, потому что вчера был лес,
грязь, сегодня чуть другой формат.
Сегодня побольше проедем. Вчера
вкатывались.
เฮ
Сейчас едем. Проехали Катон Карогай. Я
давно мечтал быть в восточном
Казахстане, и мечта моя осуществилась.
Всё огонь. Едем командой, всё отлично.
Так, ну сегодня второй день. Настроение
отличное, погода само собой. Вот команда
супер, всё профессионально. Мы на Алтае,
проехали Катон Карагай. Сегодня с утра
мы двигались только по асфальту.
где-то проехали 50 км.
Значит, по поводу разбора. Когда
смотришь на Ютубе Маргулана, как он вот
это всё рассказывает, это вроде бы
красиво, понятно всё, а как на деле,
непонятно. А вот здесь мы просто
человека, когда разбирали,
я понял, что прямо конкретно увидел, где
где у него прямо вот эти точки ээ вот
скрытые, мёртвые, которые вообще
незаметные. Вот именно в разборе.
вживую. Это получается очень круто.
[музыка]
Пейзажи космические. Идём перевалами.
Супер.
[музыка]
Не думал, даже в мыслях не был, что
здесь настолько будет красиво, как будто
я нахожусь в Швейцарии. Настолько
спокойно и в душе спокойно.
Блин, очень красиво, честно. Я всю жизнь
мечтал. У меня очень много друзей,
которые, ну, отсюда родом все обещали
уже лет 10. И в один прекрасном моменте
я просто решил её поехать на баги тур,
не пожалел вообще столько эмоций.
[музыка]
Один Баги сошёл с маршрута, непонятно,
перестал заводиться и всё. Стрелки
поднялись. Мы разобрали генератор, при
предохранители, все рыхи посмотрели,
ничего не работает. Поэтому один бак
оставляем в Катон Карагая. Ребята
пересаживаются на свободные места.
Хорошо, у нас четыре свободных места
есть.
[музыка]
Хватает всё. Вот ви пейзажи, конечно,
супер. Нам очень понравилось. И я очень
рад, что сегодня только второй день.
Впереди ещё 5-6 дней незабываемых.
Всё отлично.
Я думаю, здесь, смотрю, Швейцарии что
ли, оказывается, это прекрасно.
Казахстан, алтарь.
С утра встали дружно, собранно.
Организация очень хорошая.
Мне кажется, если бы не баги, здесь
очень сложно пройти на обычных простых
машинах. Я не говорю о городских джипах,
я говорю уже конкретно о джипах, которые
вот предназначены ездить по горам. Им и
то сложно здесь проехать.
[музыка]
Домиками живём. Да,
классный день сегодня. Супермаршрут.
Сегодня мне больше понравился маршрут.
Получил
там как, ну, именно от вождения сегодня.
Вообще, честно говоря, не ожидали, э,
что мы настолько удивительная страна
Казахстан, такие шикарные пейзажи, горы.
подушевлён просто
ехал спокойствие и наслаждался такой
природой атмосферой. Сегодня была очень
насыщенная поездка. Мы забрались так
высоко, доехали до озера Морали. Просто
космическая красота, ребята. Настоящая
Швейцария. Вчера как раз разобрали меня
и мою компанию Q4.
Очень много дал ээ советов, которые я
приехал.
сразу применять буду в своём бизнесе.
[музыка]
Также до пола
супни пять раз в
утро прекрасное, как видите, погода
замечательная, солнышко. Вот сейчас
готовимся к очередному дню. Каждое утро
у нас уже холодный вот бассейн.
Имам вот непривычно,
как раньше. Вот просто просыпался
горячий душ.
От багитуры вообще всё хорошо, всё
нравится с каждым разом. Вот вчера вот
я был вместе с Гари, он захотел
искупаться, просто залетел в речку со
всей скорости. Очень красивые, нужно
посмотреть, ну, было бы хорошо поехать и
на источники, поплавать, погреться.
Компания Maring Health занимается
продажей, доставкой и продажей японских
бадов.
Ээ очень приятно, что спонсоры заботятся
о нашем здоровье. Это как бы нужная
вещь. Лучше с молодостью ухажива за
своим здоровьем, потому что потом будет
тяжело.
Олег, тебе тоже передать?
Давайте мне. Мне
сегодня у нас третий день багитура.
Пока всё идёт нормально.
Был один сход, баги, какие-то поломки с
электроникой, но всё обошлось без
происшествий.
Сегодня нас ждут по плану два озера. Это
Язево озеро и Рахмановское озеро.
Наверное, это самое крутое место за всю
неделю, потому что купаемся мы только в
речке в ледяной,
и поэтому горячие источники - это прям
это как в супербання.
Шестой, седьмой, восьмой
тореставляй
два паспорта. Казахстан это
международный багитур получается.
เฮ
Да, сейчас будет очень интересно.
Дорога супер, кстати. Вот тут уже
граница с Россией, Алтай. Сейчас
приехали, говорят, тут очень красиво. И
будем купаться, потом завтракать. Ой,
обедать.
Ехали где-то минут 50, около часа.
Шикарный панорамный вид и не менее
шикарная дорога. Драйв.
[музыка]
по сравнению с тем, что мы ежедневно
купаемся рано утром прямо в холодной в
холодной воде.
Вода этого озера для нас прямо как
парное молоко. Вообще шикарно, классно.
Сейчас все купаемся, проходим, отдыхаем
минут 30. Всё по плану, по графику.
Подъезжает обед. Обедаем, ещё чуть
отдыхаем. У нас идут разборы, обучение.
И едем дальше.
Ещё что
у них стандарт система.
Молодёж у нас
право
замечательно, очень весело, очень
приятно всё растрясает.
Очень красивая природа, очень
замечательные люди. Всё просто
великолепно.
[музыка]
Супер. Я не ожидал такого природа
и отличная команда.
Сказал времени нет. Давай.
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
Приехали на Рахмановские ключи. Ехали
где-то, наверное, минут, а, 1 200, 130.
Была такая очень достаточно пыльная
дорога, но приехали здесь. Шикарная
природа. Одно из очередных озёр.
После, ну, что-то этот вода чересчур
тёплая. После того, как мы купались в
холодных, мы что-то это больше привыкли
к холодной воде.
[музыка]
Знаете,
я предлагаю,
возможно, вы просто его будете запивать.
Очень вас понимают.
Тоже с кедрам,
да? У нас стояло
[музыка]
в целом всё отлично. Вчера в первой моей
жизни спал в палатке под дождём. Это
было круто. Сегодня я решил, э,
проснуться на час пораньше. Я проснулся
в 6:45 и, э, любовался природой, потому
что мы в своей суете постоянно не
обращаем внимания на природу, а здесь я
кайфанул. Прямо кайфанул. Лучше, чем
горячая домашняя ванна, может быть
только речная холодная ванна. Она
включает, заряжает, наполняет и делает
нас сильнее. Всё проходит пока
нормально. За эти дни только то, что у
нас
Defender порвал только привод. Ну
нормально сейчас его вроде сделали. Один
баги у нас вышел полностью из строя.
Пока не можем восстановить.
И не знаю, один джип у нас восстановился
или нет. Сейчас надо узнать. А так, в
принципе, всё по плану. Слава
Всевышнему. Всё хорошо. С погодой нам
везёт.
[музыка]
الله
Огромное спасибо организаторам.
Очень всё чётко, влажено,
прекрасно формированная поездка
получилась у меня. Я получил куча
впечатлений.
Бомба, блин. Не ожидал, что родился в
Казахстане, что у нас такое такая может
красота быть просто нереальная.
Маршрут живописный, шикарный маршрут.
Видно, что продуманы маршрут. Всё
интересное. То есть каждый километр,
каждые 100 м они интересные.
Особенность этого места в том, что здесь
соединяются
границы трёх стран: Китай, Россия и
Казахстан.
Так, мы находимся в прекрасном месте, в
восточном Казахстане.
Как точно называется эта долина, я не
знаю, но выглядит она изумительно. А,
честно сказать, очень много за последние
5 дней изменилось. Я записал уже три
заметки. у меня уже переполнены в целом
полностью переосмысление жизни. Я каждый
день завтра, ну у себя дома каждый день
там в стрессе, постоянные звонки
бесконечные, телеграммы. И на протяжении
4тых дней, когда я был не в связи, да, я
я понимаю, что насколько это всё крочные
проблемы, это вообще не проблемы. И в
целом полностью идёт переосмысление
жизни. Я записал порядки сотни э
заметок, которые буду внедрять по
приезду Ташкен. И самое главное это
устойчиво устойчиво буду развивать и из
наших процессов буду делать привычки,
познакомиться с замечательными людьми,
вместе отдыхаем, вместе сидим, ужинаем.
Это очень интересно, очень забавно. Так,
в этом туре я понял, что, ну, в своей
сфере я сейчас один из лидирующих, но
понимаю, находясь здесь, то, что надо
ещё много работать, открывать новые
страны, направления, и это надо делать
по-иному. То есть, как раньше уже, ну,
точно не получится. Это самый главный
инсайт. Но и люди, которые здесь, мне
просто вот так открыли крышку. Здесь
что-то вот так поперемешивали. И это не
только Марланч, каждый человек что-то
здесь уже вложил. И я точно уверен, что
уже не буду другим.
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
й
[музыка]
отправить.
Всё, мы прибыли. Я очень рад, что я
вытащил ээ пятёрку.
Она очень мягкая. И дорога была и камни,
и глина, и грязь, и мосты. Вот. Но самая
крутая мне понравилась трасса Ралли
Париж Докар. Ничего не видно, просто
давишь на гашетку и вообще летишь. Ну,
прямо адреналин такой, кайф просто
супер.
Не, если честно, вообще жёсткий это
серпантин, природа,
вид, который там открывается, на самом
деле, очень крутой. Ну и плюс ко всему
этому мы вот сейчас вот заехали в
лагерь.
А жители на нас смотрели как на людей из
будущего.
Дорога дорога вообще нескончаемая. Очень
красивая, но нескончаемая дорога. Кто-то
сказал, что нам всего лишь 75 км ехать,
а такое ощущение было, как будто мы, не
знаю, 400 проехали. Мы летели просто в
пыли. Все, ребята вон до сих пор
обтряхаются. Просто море эмоций. Машины
надёжные, всё отлично.
[музыка]
Потом гру
сейчас идёт процесс. подготовки.
Выезжаем на озеро Зайсан. Тоже, говорят,
шикарные виды. Будем ехать дальше. У нас
сегодня, кстати, обещали паром.
Это будет прямо, ну, круто. На пароме,
блин, классно. Трассу выбирает гений.
Да, в целом команда очень неплохо ведёт
себя.
Опытных водителей много,
происшествий никаких не было. Всё
отлично, катаемся. Маршруты очень
шикарные. В целом,
самое главное, что здесь это то
общество, которое с нами, это
единомышники, единомышленники
Маргункалевича,
которые разделяют его ценности.
Вот классные ребята, от которых
заряжаешься, получаешь много информации,
прекрасная природа, ну и разборы,
разборы ребят.
Мы хорошо сейчас разогнались, прогрели
мотор.
Да, кайфанули только что. Да,
пыль такая. Знаешь, как
мы поняли, что у нас тачка прёт. Знаешь,
как когда даёшь газу, [__] начинает,
короче, влево, вправо. Я даже не знал,
что такая может быть у нас на моей
родине такая красота просто нереальная.
Просто, я не знаю, необъяснимо, блин.
Это надо просто съездить и увидеть это
всё своими глазами.
Вот это всё в Китай.
А граница идёт, если оттуда можете
смотреть, вот это деревья Полоса, это
река.
Граница идёт по реке, но чтобы чётко
видеть, всё, что песок - это Китай. Всё,
что зелёное - это Казахстан.
Блин, вообще,
вообще я впечатлён вообще тем, что я
путешествую по Восточному Казахстану. И
здесь очень, ну, можно сказать, весь
Восточный Казахстан расположен на самом
крутом месте по всему Казахстану.
Во-вторых, меня удивил этот факт, что
вот эти вот жёлтые пески - это Китай.
Что я сейчас просто вот смотрю на Китай,
ну, одной рукой, можно сказать, в Китае,
да,
грубо говоря,
очень круто, очень красиво.
[музыка]
Если коротко сказать о богитуре по
современным языком, значит, смотрите,
душ, ванна - это река и озеро.
Потом люкс- номер в отеле дорогом там.
Это на природе палатка, где спальне
где спишь на спальном мешке и живая
музыка, пение пти птиц разных там вообще
утром, если пош вообще там не передать
словами.
На самом деле эта поездка, каждая
поездка, наверное, где всегда идёт
тренинг
о бизнесе.
А саморазвитие и так далее. Он всегда
даёт. Каждая поездка. Это как книгу,
когда повторно читаешь, ты новые моменты
для себя узнаёшь там и фиксируешь и так
далее. Вот это именно каждая это эта
поездка с Моргоном Каливичем.
Она вот каждая повторная поездка мне
даёт каждый раз что-нибудь до
подчеркнуть. Насчёт природы можно
сказать, что сегодня особенно удивило в
том смысле, что такое
разнообразие природы вот в таком
маленьком относительно регионе, да, то
есть в одной области считать и холод, и
жара вот такая вот и пустыни, и горы, и
вообще
принятие решений - это, по сути, всегда
осуществление выбора.
Отсюда второе правило. Когда вы
принимаете решение, вы всегда принимаете
два решения. Не бывает одного решения.
Вы всегда принимаете два решения: от
чего отказаться, на чём
сконцентрироваться.
Когда человек находится в кризисе, я
говорю, это первый признак того, что он
вовремя не принял решение
когда-то,
потому что проблема в этом мире, она не
не прибегать там срочно, она сначала
появляется в виде прыщика. Ты не
обращаешь внимания, думаешь: "А прыщик,
прыщик". Потом она приходит в виде
чирика. Ты не обращаешь: "А чирик,
чирик". И она будет сигнализировать тебе
до тех пор, пока ты не примешь решение.
Понимаешь? Пока она она будет всё сложно
и сложнее формы болезни. Сложнее сложнее
сложнее, пока тебя вообще носом не ткнут
в эту проблему и ты не думать, будешь
решать.
Именно поэтому хорошие руководители
всегда говорят: "Я тот человек, который
хочет первым услышать плохие новости".
Ну, у меня там много было, на самом
деле, запросов. один
наверное основной, э, почему мне зашёл
Маргулан, и я очень хотел разбор
получить, потому что, э, по
безопасности, наверное, он самый лучший
кейс для меня, потому что как что он
прожил, что он прошёл, э, причём во всех
ээ странах там чуть бы уголовные дела не
заводили, он эту всю кухню знает
изнутри, прочувствовал, прожил.
он знает фундаментальные
моменты, как движется товар, как
движутся деньги. Вот поэтому это лучший
разбор, как бы, в моей жизни, потому что
я понимаю чётко, как выстраивать
компанию так, чтобы безопасность была.
То, что для меня вот и для моей семьи
сейчас самое важное, это номер один- это
безопасность, потому что обороты очень
быстро растут. А второй момент - это мы
отсекаем вообще все ненужные ээ
действия, которые отвлекают и не создают
огромную прибыль.
Вот. Ну и третье. Я понял для себя, что
в этом кругу собрались
значит люди, у которых даже готовы уже
мне инвестировать. Мне уже подошли,
говорит: "Ребята,
Олег, давай мы сколько надо тебе денег?"
То есть мне очень понравилось, на самом
деле, потому что это реально как бы вот
с такими партнёрами я прямо с
удовольствием бы вёл дела.
[музыка]
Так, всем доброе утро. Меня зовут
Владимир. Занимаюсь доставкой авто из
США, компания Колум Trade. А я на
Багитур с Маргуланом пришёл с запросом
переоценки своих некоторых внутренних
ценностей. Можно так сказать, себя
показать и на людей посмотреть, да.
очень много чего сравнил, очень много
получил инсайтов, а нашёл свои там
уязвимости, очень тонкие моменты, и это
всё было сделано на примере других
ребят, на их разборах. То есть меня
лично не разбирали, у меня не было
запроса, но очень много я подчеркнул,
выписал 131 задачу, которую для себя
буду делать в ближайшие 3 месяца,
распределю её. А самый главный инсайт
такой, что бизнес может быть и должен
быть сделан очень легко, с минимальным
количеством усилий и с максимальным
результатом.
Я подчеркнул от себя для себя от всех
разборов
то, что Маргалан говорит такие слова,
что эффективность в какой-то степени -
это лёгкость принятия решений и
аналитики этих решений.
[музыка]
Так, сейчас дождь собирается, поэтому
все одились дожди.
Отлично. Всё пробовали. Дождь, солнце.
В общем, вот сейчас уже по ромам
проезжать будем. Вот вот этот место
вообще вот супер.
[музыка]
Мы должны поехать на пароме
на другую сторону. Кухня заехала, все
баги остались. Теперь пришлось все
арбузы вытащить, чтобы здесь подождать.
А вы бы один ножик сюда бросили?
Было бы другой. Я смот
ребята кажется сам по себе интересен
и есть чему поучиться и
при взаимодействии
происходит такой обмен опытом. В целом
мне понравилось, во-первых, организация
правильная, да, то есть нет никаких там
моментов там простоев чего-то там. Ну
всё, да, начиная с питания, там
заканчивая палатками, мешками. Для меня
это вообще в целом впервые то, что я вот
выехал не просто на природу, а вот
вообще даль дома, скажем так.
Самое интересное и самое главное, что
удалось увидеть и послушать, это то, как
Маргулан Калеевич создаёт большие
системы, экосистемы. Вот он на примере
Багетура показал нам, как создать
экосистему, бизнеэкосистему,
которая бы работала самостоятельно и
была самоуправляемой.
Последние каждый мы по вечерам с Марум
Колевичем делали разные бизнес-модели.
Вот у каждого из участников были свои
запросы.
Погода бы была прекрасная. И вот мы
сколько дней мечтали, чтобы пошёл дождь.
И наши молитвы были услышаны. И пошёл
дождь. И как бы финишная прямая,
последний день все счастливы, все
улыбаются на ура, как бы. Спасибо
огромное
Марлан, что он такой багитуру
организовал организатором, фотографом,
ээ, кухня, лагерь. Было вообще
прекрасно, честно.
В общем, мне весь Багитур вот
понравился, особенно наши посиделки, вот
где проводили разные разборы
и наше общение сроном. Да. где мы узнали
много чего нового, особенно я я вот как
начинающий, вот у меня вот интерес есть
бизнесу, есть желание начать что-то.
И вот пока поэтому я вот собираю
примерно и пытаюсь там научиться на
ошибках других.
А так мне, в общем, вот всё понравилось,
всё слушать и особенно в добивку ещё и
баги тур добавили. На баге катались.
Спасибо папе, что отвёл меня сюда. Так
всё понравилось. Я первый раз поговорил
с Марвано.
Вот и закончился наш тур. Впечатление
положительное. Отдохнули.
Самое главное то, что
были вопросы
скептические какие-то определённые
моменты, но благодаря коллективу,
естественно, благодаря нашему
предводителю, нашему организатору
Моргалану Калеевичу, вот с каждым
разобрались, можно сказать. Так. И
оказывается, ну, по лично я по себе
говорю, что думал об одном, а зайти надо
с другой стороны. И не так всё просто и
не так всё, как оказалось.
Так, ну что, друзья, конечная точка,
просто шикарное зелёное поле. Прошёл
дождь, освежил нас, все наши машины. До
этого 6 дней была шикарная погода. Вчера
была на берегу озера Зайсан прямо такая
жарища, можно было сказать. И в плане
погоды, и в плане разбора наших
бизнесовых, мне кажется, с ребята ещё
больше сблизились, ещё больше узнали
разные бизнесы в разных странах, в
разных направлениях. Вчера было очень,
э, большой разбор, и, наверное, впервые
мы сидели практически там до 12:00. И
один разбор шёл больше полутора часов.
Сегодня с утра мы поехали по холмам, по
полям, э, очень быстро ехали, а,
увидели, что такое паром. Аэ, на востоке
Казахстана красивейшее Урминское
водохранилище. И вот сейчас мы на
конечной точке. Сейчас будем пить гори
горячий чай. Уже такая лёгкая усталость,
очень приятная, очень такая лёгкая,
наверное, ностальгия или грусть, потому
что всё это заканчивается. Ну, это
только очередная страница, я думаю, нас
снова ждут новые победы. За ними новые
приключения и новые поездки. Всем
вперёд. Прощаемся с нашими железными
конями, которые
за это время успели стать нам друзьями.
Я бы мог так сказать,
что хочу сказать. Вообще сегодня день
тоже был потрясающий. Был дождь, был
паром.
Вот мы получили массу впечатлений.
Под дождём поездили по грязи, кайфанули
по пыли, по гравике, по пустыне. Сейчас
поедем, сядем на машину и поедем
принимать горячий душ и заканчивать
спартанскую жизнь.
Есть представители и лагеря, и кухни, и
техники, и инструктора, ваши любимые все
фотографы, видеографы, всех вы теперь
уже знаете. Поэтому хотел бы от всех вас
вместе с вами поблагодарить на счёт 1 2
Спасибо, спасибо, спасибо.
Что-то жидкое, жидко.
Красавчик.
[музыка]
Время провели очень хорошо и всё быстро
пролепило.
Как первые дни думал, а зачем я вообще
сюда приехал? Ну, как в этой палатке
ночевать и на баге ездить.
Проехал тысячи и тысячи километров до
это. Ну, в итоге я очень доволен
поездки.
Здесь такими моменты, когда ты без
телефона, ты осознаёшь важность своей
жизни и ставишь правильные приоритеты.
На что нужно обращать внимание, на что
нужно проблемы превращать, задачи и
просто их решать. И вот это благодаря
Багетуру, благодаря такой красивой
атмосфере ты
действительно наслаждаешься этой
природой, атмосферой и в целом жизни.
Спасибо большое.
[музыка]